We're going to rip her way through this. Okay.
Do I need to know anything or you just want to tell me?
I'm just gonna tell you it. Okay. Maybe I'll play you some music as well. Sure.
Okay. Three, two, one. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab the podcast. That's right.
I shouldn't say it that way. The podcast. Yeah. More declarative. So we do,
you know, music is very important to the show. Very.
It's never the explicit topic, but someday it's always there.
It is the governor. Really? Yeah.
And today we're going to make it front and center.
So I thought for the next 10 minutes or so,
let me tell you about this band that we ran into.
Okay.
I don't think you mean that literally. There's not a band there,
but you had a collision. I kind of did. Well,
let me give you the back story please.
So you remember when we were doing the parasite show? Yes. Okay. Hey. Yeah,
we did several pieces about hookworms,
the first of which was about hookworms in the south. Remember this story? I do.
Just a jog. Here's a brief clip.
We think that these people are sick from something cause they don't,
they don't behave like we do. What does that mean? They are slow.
Not Mentally. They're slow. Physically they're Pale because they've got awkward.
Okay. So did you meet what you were searching for? The right music to use?
We went to our secret weapon, her name is Karen, have like,
she works a couple of cubicle rows down from us. We asked her,
do you know anything that's Kinda southern but 20 but not kind of has an edge
cause these hookworms are taking over people's minds.
So it's got to have a little bit of an edge to it does.
She gave me all this stuff and then she's like, oh check out bucan gas case,
guess gay. So to make a long story short, she handed me a CD,
this one right here called Buke and gaze a [inaudible]. And I was like, and I,
I, I as I guess totally wrong for for the show, but it was so right.
And some of the other ways that I was like, OK, so, so yeah, so here we are.
[inaudible]
I visited Bucan gaze in Brooklyn in this little basement apartment where they
play. And, uh, should we just hear some please? Uh,
I've been a fan of and gates for not yet.
It's really hard music to describe. For instance, um,
Aaron is say your last name. I'm Aaron Dyer.
Aaron is one of the members of the band. Here's how she describes what they do.
Uh,
imagine the recently retired school house janitor riding the back of a big
horse. Okay.
That's some galloping over different scenes.
Like one scene could be a really good
calm rose pedals surfaced pond,
eh, eh, Eh, eh,
jumps over that. And then it gets into another scene where there's a big part
topless beach goers that are totally pruned out and hanging out on the beach.
So they're very surprised.
And then it jumps into another scene where there's an angry mob,
forks and flames
[inaudible]
they're running after rabbits that have just stolen all of the carrots and
cabbage and they're not going to be able to eat their feast because of it the
next day. So they're very angry. Yeah.
But that's what the janitor's jumping over and he's excited about it.
And I would be too
in this scenario. Weird, weird scenario. You just vacated. I use a janitor.
So you guys a janitor on the horse? No, no.
I would say the audience would be the, uh, the janitor on the horse.
So that's how Aaron describes it. But there's another Aaron in the band,
Aaron Sanchez, two errands and here's his attendance. It's like, it's,
it's like miniature. Um,
it's like the loudest miniature first.
Oh, right. Here's bucan gates rehearsing a song called two frogs.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
oh, I was, that's as far as we got. It's so hookworm.
I mean like right from the Gecko. Totally.
Now the amazing thing is that all of that noise just came from two people just
trying to make as much noise as we can.
The reason that they're able to make that much racket is cause they've heavily
messed with their instruments. Aaron, the girl plays something called the Buke.
Buick is a baritone Ukulele or names in Buke that that is the instrument she
plays. Yes, she plays the Ukulele,
which I didn't know comes in a base flavor as yours, right? Yeah. Very cute.
It's like a miniature guitar too and wooden body.
And you notice it has two pickups.
This is a just a excuse actually taken this buke and modified it,
added some strings, electrified it with some pickups and outputs inside to add,
put sets and stare yesterday. That's the Buick. Now the gaze,
it seems even more complex. So this guy, that's what Aaron, the boy place.
This is the case. And this has basically,
this is a hybrid between the guitar and the Bass Guitar. Bass case. Yeah.
I'm just trying to think of how would it look like?
Well it actually looks just like a normal acoustic guitar,
but through the strings or bass strings it bass strings go to their own base.
Amp. The guitar strings go to their own guitar amps.
Wouldn't it be cool if the bass string was actually an elongated and taught
hookworm
can you sing on this one seven it would be hard to play cause it'd be biting
your fingers the whole time. Anyhow.
So the other thing that's happening when they play is he's beating kick drum
with his left foot. She's got bells on her ankle.
This is a really high pitched frequency.
Trask those. Yeah,
so this is like one of those people who walk around like in central Europe with
like nine instruments doing a moral simultaneously a little bit. Yeah.
Dank is one to four
[inaudible].
This is bucan gays performing from their first album. A song called bundle tie.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] long. Have you guys been playing together?
Let it 2000
and then we were in a band in 2003 called [inaudible] on an ed.
That band broke up. We broke up because we were dating at the time.
This is the first time you've ever said that. Really? Yeah.
What are you now if you mind me asking friends or band mates? Oh yeah.
Not even friends. Jesus Christ. We're friends now.
I kept trying to push him, prod the two errands about why they broke up,
but they wouldn't tell me. I probably wouldn't tell me either.
Suffice to say something happened and then they just stopped speaking to each
other for a really long time. If didn't, we didn't speak for like three years,
three or four years really. And Aaron, the girl basically moved away,
gave up music altogether and started racing bikes and then one day out of the
blue for no real reason that he can explain Aaron,
the boy writes an email to Aaron, the girl, he said,
how's so how's the cycling going or something.
I think I did say that you did. We've never really talked about it. Really?
Yeah, and beyond that, they wouldn't really talk about it with me,
but their music has something in it. Some kind of like hook where me and
[inaudible]
that maybe comes from stuff, they don't talk.
There's something about your music that feels possessed.
My temptation maybe wrongly is to say possessed by some soon.
If the history you guys have to get good, great
[inaudible] [inaudible]
if largely armies of bunnies are going to steal their carrots,
then you're just living in an anxious world. The truth is,
if you're the rabbit,
I don't think they would disagree with you there. Well,
that was [inaudible] recorded with help. Help
from Michael Rayfiel. You can find out more about Buke and
gaze@buke.com who would you spell? Buke, B U. K e n. [inaudible] g a double s.
If you have any trouble spelling it, you can just go to our website,
radiolab.org we will link you there.
And for all you New York listeners,
here's something June 1st bucan gates.
You're going to join actually join us onstage for the second installment of the
our performance series that we're calling. Um,
[inaudible]
we're going to have prune and gates on our stage.
You can make a case, but she'll be pruned out. She will, he will,
he may as well. And that's June 1st, uh, here at the green space.
Just check our website, radio lab.org for details. Oh, and by the way,
the first one that we did, which was just a few days ago, is a,
the video is now on our website as well, radiolab.org.
It was a really fun evening. We had a basically two guys talking about swarms,
swarms, you know, the science of swarms. Also kind of making art from swarms.
Very cool. radiolab.org.